I'm just gonna move on to our first
panel here on the epidemiology of HIV
and AIDS and sexually transmitted
infections among men have sex with men
I'm going to be kidding keeping all of
the intros short to save time our first
speaker is Ted white who's an associate
research scientist at the Yale School of
Public Health Ted welcome
there you go
morning I'm gonna get right into it I'm
covering pretty much a quarter century
of the history of sexually transmitted
infections among men who have sex with
men in the United States so hold on to
your bobby pins here we go something we
were all told in the 1980s is that HIV
was an equal-opportunity infection that
it could infect anyone gay or straight
male female of any ethnicity and these
were important messages to put out
because we were seeing lots of new
infections among populations that were
not gay men but things have turned
around in 2007 56 percent of new HIV
cases AIDS cases were reported among MSM
CDC has estimated that up to 70% of HIV
transmission may be occurring among men
who have sex with men and the rate at
which MSM become infected with HIV is 44
times the rate it is for other men and
40 times 3 for women this is a difficult
to read slide and I'm sorry I I can't do
the pointer thing on on both sides so
here's a limitation for today but you
see the dotted line that had a big peak
in the 1980s this is the the the number
of new infections that were estimated
using a new method of estimation by CDC
you see a huge a huge number a huge
burst of new infections in the 1980s HIV
spread very rapidly through men who have
sex with men
that's that category and now you see at
the at the right end of the screens that
same dotted line increasing whereas all
other populations the number of new
infections per year is remaining stable
or decreasing so HIV is the only
population are MSM are the only
population for which the number of new
infections is going up the only one and
it's particularly problem with men of
color I'll get into that in a minute
but what happened with that giant
increase that happened in the 1980s is
HIV the epidemiological term and I'm an
epidemiologist is it saturated the
population that is pretty much everyone
who was gonna get infected became
infected very quickly these are data
from the hepatitis B cohort in San
Francisco Bloods were taken and frozen
from gay men as part of a study for
hepatitis B which was a problem at the
time before anyone knew about HIV or
AIDS and they went back and looked for
how many guys in that cohort of 320 men
had HIV you see the first one
tested positive from a blood stored in
1978 by 1982 nearly half of them had HIV
it leveled off at about half but you see
it happened almost quickly it happened
so quickly an epidemiologist I worked
with in San Francisco said it was almost
as though somebody who put something in
the water what happened is the
population you know pretty much everyone
who became in fact who was going to get
infected became infected and you had a
large number of men in this population
died in this birth cohort what's
happened is like after a forest fire
after the forest is burned down now we
have new growth we have get young gay
men aging into they're sexually active
years and they're the young gay they are
the younger people who some of whom are
in their 40s and about my age who were
in college when all of this was
happening or high school they're aging
into they're sexually active years and
they're becoming infected so this is the
number of HIV and AIDS cases in this
states with the best reporting and you
see the number of reported cases for
heterosexual contact injection drug use
has actually gone down but heterosexual
contact is remaining relatively steady
it's going up for those reporting male
to male sexual contact a little bit
about the kind of men who are getting
HIV the group with the greatest
transmission risk is of men 35 to 44 as
is unusual among sexually transmitted
infections gonorrhea tends to strike
people
in their high school or college years
but HIV is a little different because
the older you are in with an infection
that doesn't resolve the more likely you
are to be infected so if you're in your
30s or 40s your dating pool has a higher
prevalence of HIV in it the big increase
that we're seeing is um among we're
seeing it in all races and ethnicities
of MSM but we're seeing a particular
spike you can see what happened with
blacks and on his black non-hispanics a
decrease that ended about 1998 but now
the number of newly diagnosed cases is
equal for African Americans as it is for
whites among MSM now that the African
Americans there's one African American
for every four whites in this country so
that's pretty a pretty substantial risk
differential for every racial and ethnic
group men who have sex with men is the
largest number of cases in any
transmission category it's true you know
far more white black and Hispanic MSM
than any of their heterosexual
counterparts
although the proportion of new cases
differs by race and ethnicity it's still
huge among whites it's about 55 percent
among African Americans it's 41 percent
MSM who are new cases and among Latinos
it's about 55 percent again what we are
left with is this is a this is hiv/aids
cases among MSM aged 13 to 24 in the
United States and although people of
color represent one-third of the United
States populations they're representing
three-quarters of the cases of HIV AIDS
among young gay men when we talk about
preventing HIV among youth we need to
think about whom we are preventing it
among in young people with HIV 13 to 19
newly diagnosed
cases in in the last several years 59%
of our teens diagnosed were MSM and this
these pie charts include females so all
female cases are in the the yellow pie
slice in 20 to 24 year-olds there's 65%
of the new HIV cases so if you want to
prevent HIV among teens think among whom
you want to prevent it the big now this
are those same groups 13 to 12 13 to 24
broken down by race ethnicity over the
first half of the decade that's just
ending now and you see the starkest
increase is among blacks non-hispanics
this is a huge proportion of the
burgeoning HIV problem it's among young
black MSM black and Hispanic youth or
black and Hispanic MSM who get HIV tend
to do so you can see in a second and
third sets of bars in this graph they
tend to get it at a much earlier age
than white MSM you see the modal group
the group with the most number of new
cases among whites are in their 30 or 32
39 age range for blacks and Hispanics
the biggest group is in between the ages
of 13 and 29 so let's talk some about
the issues around men of color and
here's the wacky thing although latino
MSM have similar numbers of partners and
use condoms as frequently as other MSM
they're three times as likely three
times more likely than white MSM to
acquire HIV and of great interest is
when we compare us born people with HIV
to non-us born hiv-positive Latinos the
Latinos were likely to present with a
lower cd4 count at diagnosis they are
more likely to come in with an
opportunistic infection when they learn
they have HIV and they're more likely to
wind up in the hospital when they're
diagnosed for african-american guys I
need some water excuse me
although African Americans have the
about the same number of partners and
use condoms actually a little more
frequently in some studies than other
MSM they're five times more likely than
white MSM to acquire HIV and black MSM
are tested for HIV less frequently than
other guys they're less likely to know
they have HIV when they have it and like
non-us born Latinos they're more likely
to be diagnosed at a later stage in the
disease so what's going on here well
though there are a number of factors
that might be due that might be relating
to this and this is the work of Greg
nollette who's now at the HIV aids unit
of CDC who's a really brilliant
african-american gay male researcher who
was mentored by also by Ron Stahl like I
was he's and he's done quite well
less diagnosis of HIV in these
populations which leads to unknowingly
exposing when sexual partners people who
know they have HIV tend not to have
unprotected sex with people they don't
think have HIV but if you don't know you
have HIV that's a problem and we tend to
date people who are similar to us
demographically so if you're
african-american and you have HIV and
don't know it a disproportionate
proportion disproportionate number of
your sexual partners are going to be
african-american as well so that winds
up exposing more black guys there is a
greater background of other sexually
transmitted infections bacterial sti's
in these populations for a variety of
reasons when guys are infected they're
less likely to be on antiretroviral
therapy what a surprise poor people get
worse healthcare there are greater age
differences in partnerships in these
populations we have a greater proportion
of mixing between older guys and younger
guys and because the older guys are more
likely to have HIV
they can toss the infection down the
demographic conveyor belt to the younger
guys so it transmits more and we have
denser sexual networks than among other
MSM and I'll explain what that means in
a minute
by the way we're gonna put on the
website the podcast that talks about
this that Greg nollette did and it's
really wonderful so yeah we're gonna
save questions to later I'm afraid but
but um it was the website that you
registered through and it's in your
packet so the number I talked about
networks
what does networks mean well everyone
knows the six degrees of Kevin Bacon
right you can go on to IMDB and from any
actor you can get to any other actor
that you can get from any actor to Kevin
Bacon they say in six jumps you know he
was in a movie with Gwyneth Paltrow who
was in a movie with Bruce Willis who was
dead and you can get to Kevin Bacon
well if you're in a if you're a black
actor who because of Hollywood tends to
be in a movie with other black actors
how many jumps does it take to get to
Will Smith well fewer because it's a
smaller group so from the virus i
point-of-view
you want to be in that smaller group
because you can jump to more people and
fewer relationships so are what I really
want to point out is our infection risk
is only partly influenced by our
individual actions it's largely
determined by population factors that
are beyond our control
you might you know a white person and
what I'm pointing out for men of color
and white men in this situation is true
for people of color in general this is
part of the reason why there's a greater
burden of disease it's nothing that the
individual is doing Mary and Maria might
both have three sexual partners in their
lifetime but the person with the tighter
dating pool that you see here is going
to have more risk even though she's not
doing anything different so a huge
problem with HIV infection among men of
color I'd like to point out some data
from the National HIV behavioral
surveillance survey which is done in
cities around the United States where
they pull up a campervan to outside gay
bars and they test a bunch of guys and
give them questionnaires and what they
found out is 21% of the white guys had
HIV 46% of the black guys had HIV 70
percent of the Hispanic guys and it was
about the same for other races here's
the proportion among all the guys who
had undiagnosed infection four white
guys four percent of them were running
around with HIV and didn't know it
that's among everybody thirty-one
percent of the black men had HIV and did
not know they had the infection double
what it was four white guys eight
percent of Hispanic guys had it very
important every year in the United
States 1% of HIV negative MSM get
infected with HIV it's 2 percent in
urban areas among guys who are now 18 an
HIV negative the projection is that 41
percent of them will have HIV by the age
of 40 and for African Americans the
projection is that it will be 59 percent
by the age of 40 that projected
prevalence is higher than in sub-saharan
African countries and the really the
thing that really gives me pause is
those projected HIV prevalence azar
comparable to what we what was reported
in San Francisco before AIDS education
began two-thirds of HIV transmission
among MSM this is the fun facts to know
and tell slide 2/3 of transmission
occurs between Maine partners it's more
likely to be unprotected and you have
more sex on average with your main
partner than with other partners if
you're lucky nearly 1/2 of HIV
transmissions appear to be from a
partner who had recently acquired HIV
and I'll tell a little bit about that in
a minute
sexually transmitted effect infections
are becoming more prevalent every year
one or two men gay men in the thousand
gets diagnosed with syphilis 46 times
the rate among other men 71 times the
rate among women what Chris alluded to
earlier we're definitely with syphilis
we're definitely seeing at the national
level in 2008 an estimated 4% of
syphilis was among MSM because that's
when behavioral risk was really low or
at its nadir and we also didn't how we
really we were still dealing with the
effects of the die-off that happened in
the 90s by 2008 too
nearly 2/3 of syphilis cases were among
MSM and you can see that's not because
the rate the the number of new
infections among among straight folks
went down you can see the huge climb in
the blue bar of just the numbers of
reported cases and the majority of the
MSM diagnosed with syphilis or HIV
positive gonorrhea has risen sharply in
some spots not in others but what really
concerns us is that antibiotic resistant
gonorrhea is concentrated in men who
have sex with men so where we used to be
able to cure your gonorrhea with pills
now we got to do it with a shot people
remember that so why do we care about
bacterial STI is if we can get them out
of you well they're readily transmitted
through oral sex so you can have safe
sex and get a bacterial STI and a lot of
times in the throat or the rectum if
they've been exposed there its
asymptomatic people run around they
don't know they have it they don't know
that they're giving it to their sexual
partners having rectal gonorrhea is
associated with about an Eightfold risk
and Agera bisexual men getting HIV and
having syphilis is associated with a
four-fold risk it's lower because so
many of the guys are infected with HIV
already and bacterial STI is increased
the viral load in an hiv-positive guy
making him more likely to transmit the
virus to his partners I want to say a
little bit about why HIV transmits so
readily among MSM because we're under
the impression we hear Oh everyone's at
risk anyone could get HIV anyone who has
unprotected sex well it's different for
us for again some reasons that don't you
know that aren't really relevant to
individual actions this is why the
likelihood of transmission via anal sex
is many times higher than it is for
vaginal sex as I showed earlier MSM form
denser sexual networks than other folks
do you and your partner can share an X
in common that's a very tight little
arrangement there that straight folks
don't generally have and single set we
have a single sex scenario as opposed to
a two sex scenario now what the heck
does that mean well I'll show you and
the two sex set in a two sex population
you have transmission bottlenecks a man
can transmit HIV pretty effectively to a
woman
through vaginal sex but for we all know
for the virus to transmit from a woman
to a man through vaginal sex so there's
a much luck well it's a much lower
likelihood of transmission so you have
fire breaks along the way with MSM we
have it says role versatility a
positional versatility the first guy can
top the second guy who can top the third
guy who can top the fourth guy so you
have untrammeled transmission
probabilities and you can infect a lot
of people very readily so for us
biological and network factors make
unprotected sex a lot more risky than in
this for straight people and that's true
at the individual level and the
population level so in order in a
mathematical model in order to have the
same HIV prevalence as gay men
heterosexuals would need to have three
times as many unprotected sexual
partnerships as gay men report on
average holding all else equal for HIV
transmission to die out heterosexuals
would need to average fewer than three
sexual partners unprotected sexual
contacts per year and MSM would need to
average less than one so it's a set up
and it's not something people are doing
at the individual level it's something
that happens at the population level
so if incidence is going up are we
seeing more risk well we don't have good
behavioral surveillance to tell us one
way or the other we can say for this
city for that city for the other city
but guys are going about unprotected sex
in ways differently than they used to
something that's happening now that Manu
reporting is zero sorting this is this
great little image is from a website
called bareback health dotnet that's an
oxymoron of course see Sarah sorting is
seeking partners that you think are of
the same status as yourself often with
with the intention of having unprotected
sex with someone of your own serostatus
that's different from you and your
boyfriend getting tested and you know I
always say you can have unprotected sex
with your boyfriend when you have a cat
together but this is a different thing
gay men who reported unprotected sex
with an HIV negative partner weren't any
less likely to zero convert than guys
who reported it with a with a positive
partner in a study from Seattle and why
is that
that's because of viral shedding this is
what happens with gate with your viral
load after you become infected at zero
between zero and one month your viral
load shoots up and then you develop HIV
antibodies and it becomes modulated it
goes down and it doesn't go up you know
become stable and then it doesn't go up
until disease sets in years later so
what happens with a guy you see who
Sarah swords well he gets an anti
antibody negative test in January says
to partner a oh I just had a negative
test I'm okay has unprotected sex with
him he winds up infected and during the
period his viral load is very high as
unprotected sex with guy B and guy C and
doesn't learn that he's infected until
he has a positive test six months later
in July and who knows how many guys he
got it he infected during that time so
unprotected sex with MSM is common with
in with hiv-positive MSM is common is is
not so common but it varies by the
perception of the partner Co status and
position half of HIV diagnosed guys
report unprotected sex but it's often
with HIV positives about one innate
report unprotected sex with partners
they understand to be uninfected but
that sex is often receptive about one in
six report unprotected sex with partners
they don't know so in total about one in
four report sex with have unprotected
sex I should say with partners that they
could infect mostly people are going
about things in the way they think is
responsible but what we're seeing is
enough transmission to infect one in
fifty guys who live in cities one in
fifty uninfected guys who live in cities
every year and we could wind up with the
same HIV problem that we had before we
know about HIV
I'm worried about that okay all done
oh can I Oh encore encore I have more
slides cool okay I do so before you
bring your hands I won't say who that is
but I love her yeah before we all go
what's wrong with these guys you know
everyone does something like this you
know these these you know people aren't
sociopaths by and large right people
care about their sexual partners they
want to protect their own health but
it's the stuff that we all do that leads
to this you know these aren't mental
cases or we're we're normal people
living or living our day-to-day lives
and it still happens so is there any way
I can end on a positive note just
because I like to do that this play
friend days in Seattle I love that
picture what we do is prevention
practitioners matters this is a model
that David Holgrave at CDC did where he
modeled the effect of HIV prevention
services and we would have had that big
bump in number of new infections in the
80s regardless but it would have leveled
off at a much higher level according to
his work than it did because of the work
that the Pete the people like people in
this room do so yay for Hopi changing
stuff what you do matters before you
throw up your arms okay thank you